more midterm headaches for the Democrats
with 47 days to go the party is once
again desperately trying to distance
themselves from radical policies that
are poisoned at The Ballot Box like
defund the police moderate house
Democrats let out a huge sigh of relief
when they realize their months-long
effort to pass a police funding bill
will move forward despite the far left's
attempts to sink it Squad members
refusing to back down on their anti-cop
positions by stalling the vote earlier
and Republican Congressman Steve scalise
thinks Democrats will never be able to
get rid of the defund stench
it's unreal that months into talking
about helping police the Democrats still
can't stand up and support law
enforcement their party at its core is
still embracing the defund the police
crazy idea but it's it's very telling
that the Democrats will pay lip service
to police but when it comes time to back
in the blue they walk away because they
don't support the police and why does
this all matter well voters backed
Republicans by a whopping 23-point
margin on dealing with crime which has
led moderates to spend millions in TV
ads to appear tough on the issue
Tim Ryan knows defunding the police is
ridiculous he's brought back 467 million
dollars to put good cops on the street
I trust Tim Ryan to keep our community
safe when I hear people talking about
defunding the police I know they're
wrong police officers put their lives on
the line every day to keep us safe but
it's our job to make sure they have what
they need to do it and that's a job I
take personally in the Senate I'll
protect Florida from bad ideas like
defunding the police that's just crazy
I work side by side with the police
showed up at the crime scenes we did
whatever it took to fund our police
all that comes amid a new report that
reveals Americans of Google topics
Republicans do better on like crime and
Biden's border crisis than topics that
favor Democrats all right let's talk
about the fact that it has taken months
to get this this legislation passed
there has been a back and forth among
the Democrats between the Liberals the
progressives the middle guys the end
guys all of them and it looks like today
it will pass Dana and it appears that
their funding uh these bills are
primarily going to smaller police
departments but every one of the bills
has some kind of limitation of some sort
on the police well it's it's a sort of
like infrastructure week was during the
Trump Administration it was like every
week was going to be infrastructure week
at the very beginning when they lost
well when the Democrats didn't win as
many seats as they thought they would in
2020 the moderate Democrats said we've
got a problem and one of our big
problems is this defund the police
narrative so they could have passed this
back in June and not had the entire sum
number of being branded as anti-police
they'll pass it today one of the things
is that for example smaller suburban and
Rural police forces are going to get
some money in this it just got 360 votes
and I understand that's just because
they think that the big police
departments tend to get the most money
so this will pass I just don't think
that it's going to do enough to change
the The Branding that happened over the
past three months and it's also because
they've still got the squad they still
got the statements you still got the
things that you can use but it's also
not just about the money it's about the
attitude towards police and them feeling
like they have what they need including
the indemnification that they're asking
for well you know Jesse this whole idea
of the Democrats coming out now and and
trying to convince the public that you
know we're tough on crime and I really
love Val deming's there in Florida and
even fetterman you know fetterman
amazingly uh is trying some damage
control because he called to free all of
the second degree murderers in
Pennsylvania and now he's got an ad
saying he's tough on crime I'm not mad
at my people from Pennsylvania I'm just
disappointed he wants to turn loose the
second degree homicide people in prison
he said it's because if you look at what
they've done in prison then maybe we
should give them a shot and one guy he
said learned yoga in prison judge well
that's a reason to let him go so now
he's limber enough to be turned loose on
communities so he can murder again he
chased a black man around out of town
with a loaded shotgun got a little push
back for that so his response I'm gonna
let out all of the second degree
murderers from prison like he thinks
he's going to repent
to the black community by letting out
murders as he assume that all the
murderers are black in prison and does
he assume that black Americans want
murders to be turnless in their
neighborhoods the guy's a lunatic
they're two wedg issues in the country
you said it at the top it's immigration
and it's crime and the Democrats are in
fighting on both of those issues and
Republicans have to push this hard I
can't even make sense on what they voted
for one of the bills provides grants
aimed at reining in violence
right do you guys know what they're
talking about I have no idea what
they're talking about here's another one
promotes use of mental health workers
so they respond to incidents without
police officers you know what that is
you know what that is that is a recipe
for disaster yeah I just don't
understand the real issue is these
stupid DA's these bad bail laws and as
you said the culture that thinks prisons
and police are racist and if you want to
go deeper we can go deeper it's about
fathers that aren't there it's about the
quick bucks you can make from drug
trafficking and you know I don't think
Congress has radio addressed that at all
you know um Jessica the idea of having
mental health people work in lieu of law
enforcement which is one of the bills
um I'm not so sure that that's a great
idea
I think that it's part and parcel of
obviously having police officers on the
street but also understanding that a lot
of the people who are making us feel
unsafe and we're going to talk about
this um later in the show as well are
people who are mentally ill and there
are things that can be responded to for
people that are not traditional law
enforcement they're not carrying a gun
necessarily and we can have a
multi-pronged system to try to push push
back on what's going on in mostly cities
but actually all over the country in
terms of you know the ads that are being
aired Val demmings was the first female
police chief of Orlando she's a very
serious law enforcement official she has
an incredible record when it comes to
being tough on crime that's completely
authentic there and Dana's right when
you talk about what happened after the
2020 election whip Clyburn kicked it off
your favorite Abigail spanberger talked
about this as well and moderates were
very clear but what I find interesting
is that it was only four or five
liberals that were pushing back on these
bills the progressive caucus is actually
quite large and there were a lot of
people who you would normally suspect
were going to be you know against these
bills or or want to Tinker with them and
they were all for it so obviously
Democrats understand that this is a
serious issue for us going into the
midterms and one just more generally in
terms of keeping our country safe well
in the end Greg I mean the Dems have to
try to distance themselves from the last
two years is it going to work yeah it's
pretty hard uh RDA here Alvin Bragg
helped get a rapist out I think in just
after doing 30 days and what did he do
he sexually assaulted five people
right so that's what you're up against
as a rule though you should never
criticize people when they finally do
what you want them to do you know but
I'm talking about the Democrats finally
being tough on crime but sadly they
aren't doing it for humanitarian reasons
they're doing it for political reasons
and why does that matter it matters
because it could have been done sooner
and thousands upon thousands of lives
could have been saved if it was done
sooner and the reason it wasn't done
sooner is that it wasn't there wasn't a
political need in their head that says
you know we got to get this done yeah
people are getting killed but you know
they're those people you know it says
criminals killing criminals it's not a
big deal it's really not that way but it
makes you wonder if you want to get
Democrats to care about Crime Victims
you almost have to have elections every
month you know what I mean put them
online because then they'll only care
about crime because without political
pressure they don't give an f they just
laughed at people like us when we
brought we've been talking about this
stuff for two years right we would bring
it up people would laugh at us literally
laugh at us about talking about crime
that the numbers were wrong I remember
having this discussion it still makes my
blood boil and now two years later when
it's a political local issue right a
political issue now they give a damn
I you know I Pat them on the back for
finally joining the club but there's a
lot of dead people that aren't here
right now because you didn't think it
was worth it I'm not patting them on the
back good for you Jesse that is good
yeah neither are the dead people hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else